欸，你聽過那種，公司快要撐不下去的時候，反而做出一個你可能沒想到，甚至會覺得很瘋狂的決定，結果就翻身的故事嗎？
嗯，聽過一些傳說啦，但大部分都覺得是事後諸葛。真的會有人在快要破產時，還敢放棄一個知名的大品牌合作嗎？這聽起來有點天方夜譚。
就是有！今天這個案例的主角叫 Hero Bread。他們之前跟 Subway 合作，想把他們低碳、零糖的麵包產品推出去。結果呢？單位經濟效益根本不划算，公司現金流快枯竭了。
等等，跟 Subway 合作耶，那可是個國際大品牌。即便不賺錢，起碼也有曝光度吧？而且通路穩定，怎麼會說放棄就放棄？這不是把救命稻草扔了嗎？
原文裡面，當時 Hero Bread 的代理行銷長 YuChiang Cheng 就說了，他們那時候規模太小，資源和基礎設施都跟不上，沒辦法有效供應。所以他們選擇「退出」這個合作。
退出了？那然後呢？一家瀕臨破產的小公司，斷了跟大品牌的合作，不就直接倒了？他們具體做了什麼，才扭轉局勢的？
他們轉向了 DTC，也就是直接面向消費者的策略。這樣做的好處是能更快收到消費者回饋，帶動口碑行銷。而且，他們把產品線精簡到只有五種核心品項：白麵包、帶籽麵包、漢堡麵包、熱狗麵包和麵粉玉米餅。
DTC 確實是很多新品牌會走的路，但要從現金流枯竭到真的能賺錢，這中間的轉換率和行銷成本都是大問題吧？而且只賣五種產品，會不會太單一了？
數字會說話。YuChiang Cheng 在 2023 年 11 月接任 CEO 後，公司持續成長。在今年 6 月宣布的一輪募資中，他們在不到 90 天內就募到了 2100 萬美元。去年，Hero Bread 的年營收高達 5400 萬美元。
5400 萬美元！這數字確實很驚人。從快倒閉到五千多萬美元營收，中間肯定不只是 DTC 這麼簡單。那這些錢是怎麼來的？難道 DTC 一路開掛嗎？
他們很聰明地將 DTC 作為「測試場」。像是他們的 Crafted Collection，包含可頌、司康、餅乾，還有跟 Auntie Anne's 合作的椒鹽脆餅，這些小批量手工製作、不適合大規模零售的產品，就只在官網販售。
所以他們用 DTC 來賣高單價或實驗性的產品，這樣既能維持品牌調性，又能快速測試市場反應，同時控制成本。這點其實很有意思，讓 DTC 不只是一個銷售通路，更是研發和市場調研的平台。
沒錯。而且在 DTC 穩定後，他們也沒放棄實體零售。他們花了兩年時間，把零售點從 4000 家擴張到 10000 家，甚至在 Target 也上架了。
喔，所以不是完全放棄實體，而是先轉為 DTC 站穩腳跟，再回頭進攻實體。但這會不會有點矛盾？DTC 是「禮賓級」服務，零售追求的是規模和價格，兩者要怎麼平衡？
他們的 CEO 說得很清楚。零售能讓消費者更實惠地買到產品，因為量大成本低。DTC 則更像是一個「禮賓級」的購買途徑，除了核心產品，還能買到那些不適合上零售架的「精品」。
也就是說，他們在產品線做了區隔。核心品項衝零售量，賺大眾市場的錢。特殊或新產品則放在 DTC，測試水溫，同時維持品牌形象和高利潤。這是一個很細膩的市場切割。
對啊。其實我想到，對於我們一般上班族，這個案例好像也給了一個提醒：當你手上的任務或專案，讓你感到資源吃緊、投入產出不成正比時，是不是也該考慮，出乎意料地「放手」或「捨棄」一些東西，反而能讓你更專注，找到真正能帶來成長的關鍵點？